so this is a area of interest to me and
my labs been studying this for a while
is this is why time is rubbery and can
speed up or slow down and the experiment
had never been done about why time seems
to move in slow motion when you're in a
life-threatening situation
but I talked to so many people and I'd
experienced it myself
that I wanted to study that so I found a
way to study it by by dropping people
from 150 foot tall tower and measuring
their time perception on the way down
and that plus several other experiments
we did in my lab led me to understand
that people don't actually see time in
slow motion during an event instead it's
a completely retrospective assessment in
other words when you're in a
life-threatening situation your brain
writes down memory much more densely and
then retrospectively when you look at
that you have so many details that you
don't normally have that it seems as
though it must have lasted a very long
time that's the only interpretation your
brain can make so time your assessment
of how long something took has a lot to
do with how much energy your brain has
to burn during the event and how much
footage you have of the event